it's been over two months since
prominent Putin critic Vladimir caramoza
was sentenced to 25 years in a Russian
jail he was arrested after publicly
denouncing the illegal war in Ukraine
the sentence was widely denounced by the
International Community
well I'm delighted to say that I'm
joined Now by Vladimir's wife in the
studio of
Jenny very good to talk to you thank you
very much for coming in and talking to
us on Sky
um how is your husband doing when did
you last get a chance to talk to him
good morning thank you very much for
inviting me well I haven't seen or
spoken to Vladimir in over a year
so I everything all the information that
I get about him is from his lawyers
he's still kept at moscow's fifth
pretrial Detention Center because he's
awaiting appeal and after the appeal and
I think we all understand the outcome of
that appeal he will be transferred to
strict regime to serve his quarter of a
century prison sentence for high treason
based on five public speeches that he
made on different International
platforms talking about the war talking
about political repression in Russia and
censorship on the of the media in the
Russian Federation
um has kept at the most in the most
secure block of that prison with the
most dangerous criminals because
Vladimir is considered as such and uh
this is very I would say very logical
because anyone who dares oppose the
Putin narrative
in Russia Today is seen and is portrayed
by the authorities as either a criminal
a spy a traitor or an insane person just
like it was in the Soviet times
and you're here in London to to try and
Lobby for more support obviously to help
get get your husband freed how hopeful
are you that the British government can
do something he's of course a dual
British Russian nationalism
um well it's uh it's Vladimir is indeed
a dual National and uh
um it's truly baffling for me quite
disappointing that I haven't seen any
real strong action from the British
government and it's truly buffling that
it was Canada and not the UK that was
the first to introduce sanctions against
Vladimir's perpetrators Vladimir's
persecutors these sanctions were Then
followed by the US and then the UK
joined in
the sanctions were also recently
introduced by the European Union and are
now being introduced by Norway
um and I would of course like for the
British government to step in and be
more forceful in advocating for Vladimir
because my husband survived to
assassination attempts in the past he
survived two poisoning attacks in 2015
and 2017 perpetrated by a group of FSB
operatives in the service of the Russian
State the same group that later poisoned
Alexey navalny with novichok and I
realized that my husband is being held
by the same people who try to kill him
twice and I have no reason to believe
that his life is somehow not in danger
now that he's held in a Russian prison
and has just been sentenced to a quarter
of a century of strict regime
so um you know Canada did something
amazing recently an amazingly warm
gesture of solidarity with Vladimir and
all those who stand up to Vladimir Putin
and denounce his regime and the war in
Ukraine uh Canada gave Vladimir an
honorary citizenship and uh that that
beautiful message is that the Russian
State wants to portray all such people
as traitors and Canada said well we
would be honored to have such a citizen
well Vladimir is a British citizen
and I would like for the British
government to do something just as
strong but I found out that um
uh governments around the world you know
the political prisoners crisis and the
hostage taking crisis is rising
everywhere autocrats do take hostages
and it seems that
democracies around the world don't
really have any instruments to deal with
that Rising crisis
for example in the U.S there is an
office of the presidential Envoy for
hostage Affairs and there is a specific
law
that stipulates that there is a set of
criteria that a person has to meet in
order for that presidential invoice to
take on a case and continue and begin
advocating for the person well other
Democratic countries don't seem to have
that and I believe that this is a big
problem because the crisis will be
rising whether we want it or not whether
democracies will be prepared and
equipped to deal with it or not because
autocrats will be continuing to take
hostages and I believe that a creation
of such a novice here in the UK would be
very useful have you had conversations
with the foreign office what have they
said about the work that they are doing
behind the scenes one would assume or
hope and the lack of sanctions
um well I just uh arrived in the UK
and I will have a number of meetings
during the next two days
um so I hope to hear something positive
from the fcdo from the British
government and I um well I have a
positive
attitude and I am an optimist and on top
of that I will also continue pushing and
they need to be prepared for that too I
will continue pushing for as long as
needed to get results because
um
my husband survived to assassination
attempts his life is now again in danger
and I will continue fighting for him
with all I've got do you believe you'll
get him out you believe you'll see him
again absolutely absolutely I will see
him again the
um the idea was to raise our three kids
together he's not gonna wiggle out of it
nope I need him back in the picture
doing his part
the kids miss him terribly
um
they hadn't talked to him in over a year
just recently they had they were allowed
one phone conversation with Vladimir a
15-minute phone call after 14 months of
being deprived of contact with their
father
15-minute call that's five minutes
per head per child
that is atrocious that is pure
psychological torture
and
I will do everything to bring him back
I mean we've we've heard warm words you
mentioned America there have been warm
words about your husband from America
and you talked about the this department
that they have but
lots of warm words from around the world
Canada have actually done something do
you know would you like to see America
doing more as well
absolutely absolutely and I will be I
will continue pushing everywhere
everywhere I can and well I believe you
see
um
the the idea is these people in Russia
and we're talking about hundreds of
political prisoners and thousands and
thousands of people arbitrarily detained
for standing up against the regime and
against the war we're talking about
people whose only crime is to denounce
what the current Russian regime is doing
to our neighbor what the current Russian
regime is doing to Russia and I believe
that such voices deserve to be heard and
I believe that their stories deserve to
be known because if we want an
alternative to Vladimir Putin and of
course we will all want to see a
democratic Russia that is the only
Russia that will stop being a threat to
itself and everyone else so if we want
to see an alternative there is an
alternative it's these people these
people who gave who go to grave risks
who risk their freedom and very often
their lives to stand up to the murderous
regime of Vladimir Putin and uh I will
continue
fighting for my husband and for all
those Russians who are being oppressed
by the regime and who are who risk their
lives to say that no
despite you know all the efforts by
Putin's propaganda
not the entire Russian population stands
behind Putin and his war and there are
thousands and thousands and tens of
thousands of Russians who actually
publicly spoke out and I believe there
are millions who denounce the regime but
yes are afraid to speak up by
encouraging by recognizing the fight of
those who do find the courage to do
something we will encourage more people
to stand up